SENSE IN THE CONTEXT OF THE
COURT.
I'M NOT GOING TO GET IN THE
MINDS OF THE JUSTICES BECAUSE I
HAVE A LOT OF CONFUSION ABOUT
THEIR REASONING RECENTLY.
STARTING THIS SATURDAY, YOU'RE
GOING TO MAKE SURE THAT INSURERS
ARE COVERING THE AT-HOME TESTS
FOR FREE.
THIS IS IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND, BECAUSE I KNOW THAT
EQUITY HAS BEEN A BIG PUSH.
THE VACCINE EQUITY, THE IDEA
THAT VACCINE DIPLOMACY
WORLDWIDE, BUT ALSO WHAT'S
HAPPENING HERE DOMESTICALLY.
HOW IS THIS GOING TO HELP IN
THOSE COSTS?
THESE ARE EXPENSIVE TESTS,
RIGHT?
>> WELL, AND THE COSTS SHOULD GO
DOWN.
AND SO WHAT THE PRESIDENT HAS
SAID IS ONE WAY OR THE ANOTHER,
IF AMERICANS WANTED TO GET
TESTED, AND WE WANT THEM TO BE
TESTED, WE'RE GOING TO MAKE THEM
AVAILABLE.
SO FIRST THE PRESIDENT HAS SAID
THAT WHERE YOU HAVE PRIVATE
HEALTH INSURANCE COVERAGE AND
YOU GO OUT A BUY AND TEST, YOU
SHOULD BE ABLE TO GET REIMBURSED
FOR HAVING BOUGHT THAT TEST, THE
RAPID TEST IF YOU WANT TO DO IT
AT HOME.
SECONDLY, THE PRESIDENT SAYS WE
KNOW SOME FOLKS IN AMERICA ARE
NOT INSURED.
FOR THOSE FOLKS, THROUGH OUR
BROAD SPAN OF COMMUNITY-BASED
HEALTH CLINICS WE HAVE IN
AMERICA THAT ARE CERTIFIED BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, WE WILL
MAKE 50 MILLION OF THESE TESTS
AVAILABLE FOR FREE.
SO IF YOU DON'T HAVE INSURANCE
OR IF YOU HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
ACCESS THEM BY ANY OTHER MEANS,
YOU CAN GO TO ONE OF THESE
CLINICS AND ACCESS THAT TEST FOR
FREE.
THAT'S ON TOP OF, NOW, WHAT THE
PRESIDENT IS SAYING, THAT COMING
SOON, THROUGH A WEBSITE THAT
WILL BE ESTABLISHED SHORTLY,
WE'RE GOING TO TRY TO MAKE
AVAILABLE UP TO 500 MILLION
TESTS TO AMERICANS FOR FREE.
IN FACT, THIS WEEK THE PRESIDENT
ANNOUNCED HE'S GOING TO BOOST
THAT UP TO A BILLION TESTS OVER
THE COURSE OF THE NEXT SEVERAL
MONTHS.
SO HE'S DOING EVERYTHING HE CAN
TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE ALL THE
VACCINES WE NEED, WE HAVE ALL
THE TESTS WE NEED, ALL THE
THERAPEUTICS WE NEED, AND FOUR,
TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE ARE MASKED
AS WELL.
>> THE COSTS ARE RIDICULOUS, I
KNOW I ORDERED THE KN95 MASKS
FOR MY CHILDREN, IT WAS GOING TO
TAKE TEN DAYS, COSTING $68 FOR
LIKE 25 MASKS.
THE IDEA OF THINKING ABOUT THE
COST OF THE TESTING, FOR THOSE
LUCKY ENOUGH TO FIND THE TESTS
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT, THEY RANGE
FROM 10 TO 50 BUCKS A POP.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THE AMOUNT
OF TIMES YOU HAVE ACTUALLY DO
IT, IT'S VERY IMPORTANT.
AND ONE OF THE CONCERNS PEOPLE
HAVE, AND I'M NOT GOING TO, YOU
KNOW, UNDERMINE THE FACT THAT
THIS IS BEING DONE RIGHT NOW,
BUT THERE IS A QUESTION FROM
PEOPLE AS TO WHY IS IT JUST
BEING DONE NOW.
THIS WAS FORESEEABLE, BECAUSE
YOU WENT FROM VACCINE, YOU KNOW,
CURIOUS, TO THEN VACCINE
HESITANCY, TO VACCINE
RELUCTANCE, TO REALLY VACCINE
REFUSAL.
WE KNEW IT WAS GOING TO BE AN
ISSUE TO HAVE THIS STILL
LINGERING IN OUR SOCIETY.
WHY WEREN'T THE ACTION SOONER,
CAN YOU EXPLAIN?
>> SO REMEMBER, LAURA, THAT
UNLIKE THE VACCINE, THESE TESTS
HAVE BEEN AVAILABLE FOR QUITE
SOME TIME.
IN FACT THE PCR TESTS, WHICH ARE
THE TESTS YOU SEND INTO THE LAB
TO GET THE RESULTS, HAVE BEEN
AVAILABLE FOR -- AND THEY WERE
SITTING AROUND, PEOPLE WEREN'T
USING THEM.
BUT WHAT'S HAPPENED NOW IS
OMICRON.
INCLUDING PEOPLE WHO ARE
VACCINATED, LIKE YOU, LIKE ME,
ARE GETTING TESTED, AND WANT TO
GET TESTED.
AND THE RESULT IS YOU HAVE A
MUCH HIGHER DEMAND.
AND SO THE COMMERCIAL MARKET
WHERE THESE TESTS HAVE BEEN
AVAILABLE HASN'T KEPT PACE.
THE PRESIDENT SAID THAT'S
UNACCEPTABLE.
THE COMMERCIAL MARKET, WHICH IS
SUPPOSED TO BE ABLE TO MEET
DEMAND, HASN'T DONE SO.
SO WHAT HE HAS DONE IS PUT THE
FORCE OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
BEHIND THE EFFORT TO TRY TO GET
US THOSE MASKS FASTER.
WHETHER IT'S BY GETTING PEOPLE
REIMBURSED FOR THOSE THEY BUY
COMMERCIALLY OR BY MAKING THEM
AVAILABLE, AS I SAID, EITHER
THROUGH THESE COMMUNITY HEALTH
CLINICS OR THROUGH THE PROCESS
OF GETTING 500 MILLION NEW TES